promenez-vous dans louiseville avec ruth
ellen brosseau et vous avancerez bien
lentement merci d'aller bonne journée
la députée sortante connais beaucoup de
gens et semblent bien apprécier dans
berthier-maskinongé dans à peu près
toutes les activités de petits villages
est présente à voir les gens elle les
appelle par leur nom ce jeune fille qui
quitte anglophones qui appela par les
français le madame brosseau a fait sa
job
un autre beau mieux je me compte des
inégalités
je sais comment c'est d'or a cédé
rejoint le les deux bouts en france moi
moi je les ai vécus comme avant d'avoir
le son en politique donc je connais bien
la réalité a déjà élu lors de la vague
orange de 2011 sans même avoir fait
campagne sans rien connaître de la
circonscription
ruth ellen brosseau a tout de suite
adoré son travail de député réélu par
presque 9000 voix de majorité en 2015
elle a pris racine et possède maintenant
avec son conjoint
cette ferme de sanglier à yamachiche
j'ai fait beaucoup de chanel depuis 2000
ans ses soeurs et maîtriser les dossiers
jeta capable de partir des collations
avec tout le monde je suis vraiment
quelqu'un de rassembleur mais de
nombreux électeurs ne voteront pas pour
elle au mois à cause de la densité que
j'ai décidé de voter pour libérer
l'afrique et la faim la belle ouvrage et
reste la bla pour contester des radeaux
les rouges bible vous êtes un peu mais
là bas on ne sait pas encore je suis ok
c'était même si vous aimez beaucoup ont
voté oui mais disons que politiquement
je préfère y est
yves françois blanchet qui dimanche
dernier est venu participer au festival
de la galette de louiseville un appui au
candidat local alors que le blog pense
pouvoir gagner la circonscription votre
choix est fait pas mal collection
parfait on est dans la bonne celle là
déjà en 2015 était gentil avec nous
cette année sont contents de voir yves
perron ne s'attaque pas à ruth ellen
brosseau mais plutôt à son parti vous
savez qu'il ya une péquiste un parti qui
est centralisateur font beaucoup de
promesses en soins de santé ainsi de
suite pour empiéter encore dans les
champs compétences québec
nous on est la voix du québec la grande
espérance à lille candidate poteau
devenue politicienne vedette
ruth ellen brosseau survivra-t-elle à
cette élection victoire ou défaite
elle ne partira pas sa vie dit elle est
maintenant ici ici jean-sébastien
cloutier radio canada louise vie